as a long summer of strikes loom on the
railways in exam halls and telecoms
firms
old labour heavyweights making their
positions known so how do you make sure
people are protected to inflation-proof
them
the shadow transport minister sacked two
days ago for backing strikers on the
picket line once more i think that's a
crisis that kierstarm was making no
labour mp should ever be told by any
labour leader that you can't go on the
picket lines we are the party of the
trade union movement the labour party
was created by trade unions last year
they received nearly nine and a half
million pounds in donations from the
union 73 percent of their total private
income but those donations have fallen
since kirstama took over from jeremy
corbyn and last year the major union
unite cut much of their funding saying
that the party needs to defend workers
we've always told shoulder shoulder with
our trade union colleagues they're an
important part of the labour family and
we have different roles to play in this
the trade unions of course has to
organize and make sure that workers have
that collective voice when they don't
feel that they're being listened to no
stranger to a picket line himself
kirstama is now trying to carve a more
centrist position he's been criticized
for mixed messaging on strikes and
renationalization
and union ties are straining from where
i'm sitting it looks to me
like labor want to win an election uh
without any principles and i think
people will see through that over time
i think our own members will feel really
you know unhappy about the way that
labour are dealing with these things
there are those who criticize kirstama
for moving away from policies appealed
to the left of the party when he won the
leadership but others think that in a
general election politicians on picket
lines could lose the party's swing votes
and this weekend rail strikes will again
bring parts of the country to a halt and
there's talk of coordinated action
kirsten has reignited a split with a
left that's playing out on the picket
line if ties with unions sever
completely he'll be leading a very
different labour party ali fortescue sky
news